>>Adam: Great, thank you.
So you take your jete role,
you need to run that way.
>>Cristina: The power of arts
education is that the students learn
that it's okay to make mistakes.
It's okay, to fumble.
It's okay to make bad work.
In fact, you need to make bad work
in order to get to the good work.
>>Cindy: We're a state-wide
charter, created so that students
from across New Mexico could
access arts programming,
and academically prepare for college.
They attend a dual curriculum program.
They're in the academic
block in the morning,
and then arts block in the afternoon.
>>Serena: [singing]
>>Serena: At two o'clock
every single day,
we work on art, we hone it, we practice.
And those periods are really us
learning how to perform in others
with a smaller group first.
And when you get up and you don't your
music, it's not great, it's not fun.
You have to put the work in.
It's required.
There's no way to get around it.
>>Geron: The strengths and skills
that these artists come to us
with are hard work, and just
a willingness to keep trying.
They have perseverance.
They take constructive criticism
well, and they build on it.
>>Serena: There's so much going
around him, and despite all of it,
he's still happy, and
he's still playing.
>>Student: So I'm gonna
disagree that he's happy.
I don't think he really is wrapped
up in his own fantasy either.
>>Serena: Being able to accept
critique and not feel hurt
by it is an important skill for us to
learn, and we're taking those critiques
and learning how to put them to use.
>>Santana: So many times when
you have people critiquing you,
they will tell you, "Take it back
to the beginning and start again,
because you'll discover things
that you didn't find before."
>>Teacher: Good, all
right, so when you get here,
make sure you get a really clean pedal
on the B-flat, but that was great.
That's the kind of energy you want.
>>Santana: I take their feedback, and I
use it to construct something greater,
rather than taking it hurtfully.
>>Brass: I kind of take it
upon myself to come and listen
to Santana play sometimes
and give her a little bit
of sage advice from the senior.
The feedback is a second set of ears.
>>Brass: There are almost two
conversations, two lines, two waves,
and the real illustration--
>>Neil: When people say
practice makes perfect,
and practice doesn't make perfect.
Practice makes permanent.
So if you practice the
mistake over and over and over,
you have just gotten
really good at a mistake.
So I think it's important to recognize
and then explain it to the students.
As long as they're learning from
those mistakes they're moving forward.
>>Class: [applause]
>>Joey: You will be seeing
the fundamental students doing
"Working in Silence."
So you'll see the piece.
The faculty will give a
little bit of feedback,
and then they will do it again.
>>Joey: I believe that you
don't end on a mistake.
In the education process, you
know, oftentimes it's, "Okay,
you did that wrong; tomorrow we're
going to move on to something else."
So even in my rehearsal process,
it's like, "Let's correct that.
Let's end with a victory, or you
getting something out of it."
>>Kara: We've been getting to do
them a couple of different times,
which really helps, because then
we get to take the feedback,
and we get to apply it, and that
is the whole learning process,
is that if you fail, then you
know, you can do it again,
and you can just make big leaps
and bounds and learn from that.
>>Camille: When we working with
this scene before in the classroom,
we got a lot of negative feedback,
and it was totally trashed
and our teacher said,
"Well, it's workable."
[laughs] and we're like,
"What does that mean?"
So we decided together
that we would change it,
and decide to make something
new and better.
>>Teacher: You haven't
pulled it off yet.
Right now we're scratching our heads
and wondering why these two mutes
[laughter] have bumped into each other.
And yeah? So--
>>Joey: It's hard to hear criticism,
because who in the heck wants to fail?
Who in the heck wants to do it wrong?
So they have to think back,
reassess, do it right.
And then they own it.
>>Joey: Because you're
going to do it again,
do you have a sense of
what we're asking?
>>Joey: Okay, go ahead!
>>Camille: This is the place to fail.
If you're gonna fail
anywhere, it's here and now.
>>Camille: And because of your
failure, you can go somewhere better.
>>Cristina: Great art comes from
risk-taking, from being willing to fail.
That's something that is so
unique to learning in the arts.
>>Adam: Failure is inevitable.
Critical feedback is essential
to growing oneself as
a person in the world.
>>Adam: Good!
>>Cristina: It's just so
great to watch a student go
through that process of struggle.
Have a teacher believe in them.
And then at the end, they really have
a result that they can be proud of.
>>Class: [applause and cheers]